what's going on everybody and welcome to
my if elif else tutorial video for
python 3. the idea of this is to add yet
another layer of logic to our
pre-existing if
and now else statement see with our
typical if else statement the if will be
checked for sure
uh and the else will only run if the if
fails but what if you wanted to check
multiple if statements
well you could write them all in so you
could have if blah blah if blah blah
blah if blah blah though this is really
somewhat improper if you actually desire
every single if statement to be checked
and you actually want it to be all in
like one big grouping because without it
if you have multiple just multiple ifs
the else is only going to apply to the
last if statement so
um
so there's nothing wrong with writing
multiple ifs if they're necessary and
you want them all to run and you don't
want them to be like tied together in
one big loop otherwise you should use
the l if statement
so uh and the lf is uh again short for
else if basically so
let's go ahead and start so we're going
to say x equals 5 y equals 10 oops
and z equals 22.
so
what we're going to do is we're going to
say if x is greater than y
print
x is greater than y so we know that's
going to fail but we'll throw that there
anyways
l if x is less than z
print
x is less than z
so we're pretty confident that's gonna
uh work out for us
uh else
we'll just say print
uh if and l if
maybe multiple elifs never ran
save run
and it turns out one of our statements
what did indeed run and that is the x is
less than z
but we can come down here
and we could even add even more
statements like we could say l if um
5 is
greater than
let's see let's let me think here let's
see x is less than z so what if we did
something like this five is greater than
two
colon print
um
five is greater than two so in the old
fashioned way of doing our like multiple
if statements this statement would would
reign true and trigger the printage of 5
is greater than 2. but here let's see
what happens
we'll save and run it and again we only
got x is less than z now the reason this
happened is this is all one big loop so
basically it's asking if this is the
case do it l if do this l if do this but
what happened was this was triggered as
true and then the rest of this uh block
that's all tied together was broken and
it and it just left right and that's the
idea of the elif is as soon as it finds
something that's true it's not going to
continue searching
to see if it's true so
by the same token though we could do
something like this lf equal equal equal
equal
and then we could run this
and then it but and in this case it
finally got to this else statement and
nothing ever ran so indeed it printed
out if and lifts never ran for us
so as you can see the lift statement
kind of does indeed it just adds one
more layer of logic to your script
or your program but at least in this
case it's just a simple script
but it adds one more bit of logic to it
where you can kind of start tying these
things into into each other and using
their properties to actually start
building some pretty interesting uh
logic
so anyways uh that's going to conclude
the if elif else
i don't know i would say pairing but
it's not pairing anyways the putting
together
and uh so hopefully you guys learned
something new hopefully you guys are
enjoying the learning python and all of
that if you have any questions feel free
to post them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all your
support and your subscriptions and until
next time